an entire horizon of white assia clothes
and it is heart the world tree Pierce in
the heavens this this is the world we
call home Xenoblade Chronicles - is
every bit as fantastical as you'd hope
an RPG set in a massive world where man
and animal live on the backs of
tremendous beasts in a sea of clouds
it's a magical place that appropriately
sets the stage for an epic adventure
that gets more interesting as it
develops but this greatness comes dozens
of hours into the game the 80 plus hours
it takes to complete the story won't
feel like time wasted thanks to the
game's incredible scale and depth but
the bad taste of its lesser qualities is
never completely washed away
despite the achievements that ultimately
save the day by coming to this place you
can save the world
save it from the slow demise that is its
fate we wouldn't have to live in fear at
the start our cliched hero Rex is a
naive and upbeat salvager who
unwillingly gets wrapped up in contract
work with the game's soon-to-be villains
they seek a legendary sword which in
this case is the weapon manifestation of
a human-like being known as a blade when
a human resonates with a blade as Rex
does with his objective pyrrha a
lifelong partnership forms the two
ultimately seek Pyrus heavenly homeland
Elysium and must fend off would-be
captors and major environmental
obstacles along the way
anyone familiar with Xenoblade
Chronicles will rightfully recognize the
ways to delay to sets you up to be
surprised in the end as characters
gradually reveal secret thoughts unveil
unexpected backstories and make moves
that catch you entirely off-guard
these thought-provoking revelations
reshape your understanding of the world
and the point of your participation but
long before the story delivers these
compelling beats you are thrust into
predictable scenarios and presented with
poorly voiced characters from one scene
to the next
once again the stout and furry nopon
creatures are an annoyance on par with
Jar Jar Binks harming would be dramatic
scenes the moment they open their mouth
you can only ever travel as a party of
three but with a blade standing behind
each character or driver the real-time
battles are frenzied displays still -
xenoblade - gives you enough room to
breathe and strategize every character
will dish out basic attacks
automatically which in turn fuel more
advanced skills and how you manage this
process and the numerous other battle
mechanics can make or break your success
against the game's tougher enemies
one of the major issues of Xenoblade two
is that it fails to adequately educate
you with flyby tutorials introducing
cascading mechanics and terminology
that's easy to mix up the flow of combat
works as follows your auto-attacks fill
up a meter tied to abilities known as
arts arts fuel another meter for special
attacks special attacks can be linked
from one character to the next to build
up a blade combo blade combos seal away
certain enemy abilities and team chain
attacks based on a meter that is also
used to revive fallen teammates can
break these seals to create an elemental
explosion that deals hefty damage which
successfully extends the chain attack
for another round enemies can also be
forced into tiers of vulnerability by
breaking their defense toppling them to
the ground launching them into the air
and smashing them back down provided you
execute these moves before countdown
timers run out with abilities linked to
cooldown timers that you've hopefully
kept track of along the way there are
other systems that exist on a per
character basis but those exclusions
notwithstanding there's already a lot to
keep track of success comes from
managing timers and meter charges and
firmly grasping your available options
the latter of which is more demanding
than the game initially lets on
thankfully zouna Blade 2 feels
appropriately balanced to account for
its learning curve it's not until later
in the game that mastery becomes
paramount the frustration arises however
from the lack of reference material
which makes your desire to improve or
your ability to chase hidden paths with
dangerous enemies and great rewards
difficult to realize at first take
screenshots when the game presents you
with the tutorial because once you move
to the next text bubble that info is
otherwise lost the only other recourse
you have is to purchase bite-sized tips
from informants throughout the game
though linking partial tutorials to a
merchant is hardly user friendly variety
is good but see no blades who throws you
into the deep end a bit too early for
you to appreciate the value of
everything at your disposal
[Music]
we can do this all day
Xenoblade to encourages you to build a
massive team of blades by collecting and
bonding with core crystals which are
found in chests and dropped by defeated
enemies despite three tiers of crystals
normal rare and legendary you're never
guaranteed to get one of the game's
elusive rare blades from crystals you
find in the field save for a few varying
body types the vast majority of blades
you require look nearly identical looks
obviously aren't everything and even
common blades are useful as they each
come with randomized buffs and stat
bonuses that can make a big difference
in battle but rare blades have unique
designs their own side quests and a
larger selection of skills and stat
bonuses than common blades it's easy
enough over time to fill out your party
with rares but opening core crystals
becomes less attractive as diminishing
returns set in opening 50 core crystals
towards the end of the game you'll did 0
rare blades despite having only unlocked
half of the rare roster
to combat the randomness of core
crystals you are joined by a blade early
on named poppy an artificial life form
that you can customize to your liking
the concept sounds great but unlocking
parts to modify poppy requires you to
play a slow and shallow retro game
called Tiger Tiger at a specific
location in the game this long-winded
process isn't enjoyable enough to see
through and not worth sidelining your
efforts elsewhere with blades that you
can raise organically through comment
[Music]
blades outside of your core party can
also be trained by asynchronous murca
missions and they return after a fixed
amount of time with rewards and
experience that goes towards developing
their secondary abilities field skills
for example traits such as lock-picking
focus and leaping power will allow you
to access elite treasure chests and
shortcuts throughout the game there are
very rare instances when you are gated
by a door that requires mastery of
certain field skills though these are
exclusively linked to abilities shared
among story-based blades even in these
situations you're never truly stuck
Xenoblade - lets you fast travel
instantly to any major location in the
game regardless of the context in the
story this is great in a pinch but it's
incredibly illogical you should not be
able to warp out of the location to buy
equipment across the world during a
mission where your main objective is to
escape imprisonment but its inability to
affords you that option
Suda blade twos many systems are part of
what keeps you intrigued even as your
play time approaches triple digits but
it's the vast and wild world that draws
you deeper into the game beyond your
main quest on this and many other levels
Xenoblade to exhibits admirable depth
that is equal parts pleasing and
frustrating but the struggle to keep up
with everything thrown your way is
ultimately made worth the effort it's
often clumsy nature keeps it from being
the next groundbreaking switch game and
it will be a tough pill to swallow for
people who aren't accustomed to the
typical cliches found in many Japanese
RPGs the xenoblade's who is worth
pursuing if you've got enough patience
to let it blossom we're good
you